[Music]
okay everybody so
this is my spoiler review
of shadow and bone season one
disclaimer i will be talking about every
single episode here so make sure you
watch the full season first
then come back to this review in the
meantime you can watch my spoiler free
review of the show on my channel
disclaimer here i have not read the
books i don't plan on reading the books
so please just for everyone watching
here this is not
to discuss the books down below no book
spoilers only stuff we've seen in the
show
nothing ahead of time so i'm going to
break down every episode so going into
this episode
one a searing burst of light a big issue
with the writing in the first episode
is there's a lot of telling and not
showing in character descriptions and
what they're about
so instead of showing us that a
character is loyal
by his actions they're telling us you'll
see writing in this episode like you're
the religious one there's even a line
where someone goes
you don't seem like one who does what he
should and there's a line where someone
asks
do you know who i am and they respond
yeah you're the leader of so and so so
that's just criminal writing right off
the bat if you're
trying to set up all these characters
there's a lot of names they have to
cover
do it by quickly just showing them in
certain scenes and setting the mood with
music around that
character instead of just telling us now
you see from the trailers there's going
to be this big
villain clearly all in black and ben
barnes who is always amazing he plays
the general here i do like in episode
one we only get a glimpse of his back so
it adds a suspense to when we actually
see him
in the front and i absolutely love this
actress playing the main character of
alina so
right off the bat what's strong about
the show is that it has two strong
actors as the main leads here with ben
barnes and
the actress of elena now with alina's
character in the beginning she's a lot
more frustrating she makes some dumb
decisions like here she burns the maps
so then
now her whole crew's got to go through
the fold and she also won't let mal
go alone on through the fold so she
decides just to go and she
doesn't even know she has powers you
have to even pull this off but
she will learn as we will in this
episode that she has this power when
she's on the ship
and she's the sun summoner but you see
the b plot here with kaz
they're setting up in his story and that
he's put on a ticking clock now
to get the sun summoner elena and he's
got to have by sunrise's plan for
his crew across the fold to do this so
this episode was good
setup it's not amazing it doesn't really
suck you in yet
a lot of names you got introduced to and
you know with fantasy shows this is
gonna happen it's gonna take
more setup than a regular type of genre
the music also here was a little bland
there wasn't really those
musical scores that you would remember
and attached to shadow and bone that
kind of just background noise and i'm
conflicted at the start about the actor
of kaz
that's where i'm at episode 1. but
episode 1 i will give a 7.9 so episode 2
is titled we're all someone's monster
so we're getting our first glimpse of
ben barnes in his face now as the black
general and
we learned that elena actually as a
child skips the test for being
aggressive now this whole side story
though with pekka collins and kaz
i started to zone out fast and this kaz
versus helene story it's not that
interesting if you're going to have
a story get a lot of screen time as the
bee plot taking away from the main plot
that's trying to engage you you got to
be really careful it has to be super
interesting and just for the season as a
whole
i really don't think the cat story got
interesting until the plots actually
intersected when it was on its own it
was suffering and bringing the story
down in my opinion i will say though
right off the bat anish and jasper
are definitely scene stealers and got to
be fan favorites here
both actors are great and their
characters are really good it's
interesting they go with anish as a
assassin with knives but she doesn't
like to kill so i was conflicted because
you always kind of want to see someone
with that many knives actually just like
cut up some people here but i get it
it's different like
she's conflicted about what she's doing
so i appreciate that so
where this show suffers the whole season
is in its action sequences
the first one that stood out to me that
struggled was this action sequence in
this episode in the woods
when the carriage of greece should get
attacked by military the problem is a
lot of action you see in the show
for example like in the scene is a
grisha will like fight back
and they're literally just shooting like
a speck of dirt
up in the air or like a cool little
breeze of wind to flap their hair it's
very strange it doesn't have that impact
it's got to be stronger
and i'll get more into that with the
action because this is kind of a
repetitive thing going on where there's
some good moments in the action but
a lot of just kind of laughable weak
actions by people that don't give you
that bam that especially you need in
like a fantasy show it was cool though
every time we see
magic used by the black general here and
he uses it to cut that guy in half
but we learn more about his intentions
and that he wants to use elena to
destroy the fold from within and that
alina now knowing she's a grecia doesn't
want to accept this
part of the season she's having trouble
accepting now who she's learned that she
really is this whole time
what i love about ben barnes as a
villain is that
he plays the line perfectly always like
he did in westworld like he did in the
punisher where
you know he's bad but you still kind of
want to like him and trust him and
that's how he affects the characters in
the show too and
it really does come off so well by his
acting to the audience
something i really didn't like in this
episode was when mal decides he's gonna
go after
elena his two friends tweedledee and
tweedledum say don't do that you'll get
killed
and he just goes fine and he goes back
and just chills in his tent
that was so strange like this guy's on a
mission to save
the one he truly cares about and they
say don't do that he goes okay and he
just leaves and goes back
to sit down that was just silly and
another thing you see in these first
episodes is they really overdid the same
imagery
of mal and alina as kids going to adults
and them holding hands they just
constantly kept playing this emotional
beat where you got just sick of it it
was so recycled i think we saw it at
least five times in two episodes so
i'm actually gonna give this episode 7.6
where i think it actually went down a
bit
from the opener so episode three titled
the making at the heart of the world you
get this new setting with alina now in
the little palace
and then this is where something i
dislike the most this whole season is
introduced with this character
of nina who is captured on this ship
and the problem with this storyline is
that
it's adding now a third c plot
to the whole story and especially if you
do that it better be great
and it now is adding that right now at
the moment in the show the cast story is
not that interesting so you're also
adding in a story that's even less
interesting taking away from the most
interesting story at this moment
in the season which is the main story
and the problem is you see a lot of
fantasy shows all want to be the next
game of thrones
and they're not trying hard enough to be
their own way to do things and to stand
out and
a fresh way of structure and it's really
hard to pull off a game of thrones
did as a whole doing so many story lines
and making you interested in all of them
it's not easy to do and the nina stuff
never gets better to me but i'll go more
into that and where this episode really
struggles in the cast story line is the
stories basically
they have to gather ingredients now to
cross the fold
that never makes for compelling
television just gathering stuff
that's just a task and it's a task on
the audience but where there's some good
writing with kaz
and relationship is that
he believes hope is dangerous but she's
more of a believer he's not so that was
kind of good
set up between their relationship and i
do think that pays off in the end but we
see now
the general wants to put alina's powers
on display and we also see that this
character of zoya who is a grecia
is like the draco malfoy to alina's
harry potter here
just a bully calling her a half breed
and those pretty cool sequence where
alina picks her out
to be the one to fight when they're
training and we get our first glimpse
of this mystical stag which was awesome
but another pet peeve i had with the
writing in this episode was actually
they write a line where someone will say
to elena like careful the librarian's a
weirdo and then like the next scene we
see the librarian and he's a weirdo
why tell us just let us see that for
ourselves let his behavior show that you
don't need to hold our hands like that
so then we meet this creepy lady in the
cave
whose name is bagra and she's mysterious
she's telling lena come back to me when
you actually believe in your powers but
elena's struggling here with herself
she's having this narration that she
actually misses her life with maul and
where even if she didn't have
a bunch of clothes like she has now food
she'd prefer that i like the liner she's
like getting lost can even happen when
you know where you are
but the problem is we're at episode
three now in the show is still not
really hooking
you in and it's adding the third story
with nina on a ship with these grisha
captured i don't think that's something
that's gonna be like yeah i'm in now
i'm sold i want to keep watching this
show and give my time to it so this
episode went down a little more for me
i'm gonna give it a 7.4
now episode four i'm not going to try to
say the title it's a crazy title but
what they said up here is that the black
general wants
someone to find this stag for him and
mile miles up for the task but where
there's
more cringe writing is why oh why do
they do this where
they have the general sent her a black
outfit
and her color's blue and she's like hey
i'm not wearing that that's not my color
like come on that's like just a
kindergarten story there
like yeah black's a bad color and she's
not the bad person it's so
on the nose and then again this kaz
heist going on the side
i don't think having his motives just
getting money for this
is making this heist enough interest to
us it's like
busy work and then we see more nina's
stuff on this boat that's just taking
too much time from the episode here
what i did like in this episode was
these characters are called tweedledee
and tweedledum
mal's friends michelle and dubrov they
are really funny in a lot of the scenes
especially when looking for the stag
but the other issue i had in earlier in
these episodes
is it took a little too long for them to
develop the black general as a villain
because at the moment you don't really
know yet you feel he is
but the problem with that is it starts
to make the show feel like it's
wandering because
the only main antagonist at this point
is still
the fold that's really it so you don't
really have that central focus of
something being
a antagonist to our main character
protagonist
elena but once that comes about then the
show picks up a bit but what
really frustrates me is if you make the
main character and elena have
too many just dumb moments that make you
not
root for her anymore connect to her or
make her less likeable
right one for me that was huge was that
she was getting so upset that mal wasn't
writing her but she should
know she should be smart enough to know
she's the most protected person on the
planet right now
and that someone's got to be interfering
with letters he would try to write
like come on this guy's in this poor
country you know where he's from in the
situation he's in and you still expect
him
to get letters to you like what do you
think this guy's got air fedex
and then she's so angry about it she
runs to the bagger now
that's her motivation to finally embrace
her powers
and decides i want the scar between us
rid of two which is just so extreme
and alina looks at the black outfit
just i roll and then mal getting the
stag survives almost dies but we lose
the two funniest characters so
far in the show and twitter the intruder
which kind of sucks but this episode was
a little better than the previous one
starts picking up a bit i'm going to
give it a 7.9 now episode 5 is the first
episode i actually
enjoyed not the first half of it but the
second half this episode is titled show
me who you
are it starts with a snail pace we get
just again this
on the nose writing like jenny is saying
go back to your blue color soon and
she's like no i'm sticking with the
black going forward
but elena's now feeling like she belongs
not feeling like an outsider anymore
embracing herself and her new grisha
powers
and she gets on stage to display herself
in the black generals like she will
bring liberation to us all and the music
got a little better here too
it was are starting to get more
interesting and have its own voice
but where it starts to get cooking now
and enjoyable is because
every plot line starts cross and
intersecting now and now they're all
feeding each other where
mal gets the palace kaz's crew gets to
the palace and mao's telling the general
he found the stag
and it's the first scene i felt tension
with was with mal
and the general and he's like i'm not
telling you until you
tell me where elena is you have
something you're rooting for here
we're really seeing the general now as a
villain and then it gets cooking because
it gets a little twisty because
then the bad girl ladies like we can't
let him get that mystical stag talking
about the black generals you're like oh
okay what's happening here
i love the touch of the general giving
her the blue iris flowers
just because mal said she liked those
he's such a snake
and we get this first big twist of the
show where bagra
tells alina that the general is
alexander the black heretic
and that he made the fold and that she
is also shadow summoner and that she's
his
ma and that he created the vulca in the
fold and that they were once
men women and children which is crazy
also that he's eternal he's lived so
long he's had many names and he wants to
be able to enter the fold and weaponize
it
so you're fully getting now him painted
as a villain and what his goal is
i love you also to see anez throw the
dagger to save kaz here
and again interesting she feels guilt
for killing but then when the general
realizes elena's gone because the mom
helps her find a route out elena makes a
silly mistake
and jumps into the carriage that belongs
to cass
but the second half of this episode
finally got me sitting up for the first
time in the show again everything's
colliding now you're starting to get
some payoffs so i'm gonna give it 8.7 i
thought this was actually
a very enjoyable episode now as i got my
hopes up here
episode six brought my hopes down again
episode's titled the heart is an
arrow so this conductor was actually
going to end up
swindling kaz's crew that's what he
tells a general
just a weird character the conductor and
i didn't really buy
him being like that but black general
gets rid of him and elena
very quickly gets away from kaz's gang
but where
this show was the worst was with the
scenes in this episode
with nina and the witch hunter mathias
there's scenes where they're playing
footsies trying to stay warm together
cuddle and flirt they're both holding up
awkwardly the sheets so they won't be
naked in front of each other and i'm
still
through all this trying to figure out
why i should care about any of this
nina's storyline and they're doing all
this flirting now in the snow it's like
their best jon snow
and egret impression here and then she
falls through the ice and he gets her
out it was so
so silly and i know book readers are
gonna flip because they're gonna tell me
in the comments
oh you know nina's gonna have a huge
storyline coming up you'll see
i totally believe you but this is from a
person who's watching the show when i'm
getting in a season of a show
and if that's the case just cut her
scenes down and then have her maybe
appear at the end of the season like
we're getting so much intro sure our
story might turn great i haven't read
the books but
right now it's not and then i really
have an issue with the camera work here
in this episode that happens in the
scene with maul
and alina when they're talking in the
woods together about not writing letters
to each other figuring out this drama
blah blah blah
but you'll see about 20 minutes in this
episode they're not even lining up right
they're eye lines so it's disorienting
you as a viewer
i wonder if anyone else noticed this but
it was so obvious to me it wasn't even
like i won't point that out unless it's
really obvious but it was because
alina's looking at mal here you can
watch but mal's not actually
lined up to look at alina from melina's
perspective so we're like
where the hell is everyone looking like
it's not matched right
which is just really not good especially
for a big hyped up netflix show
that should have been taken care of and
this is what i'm talking about where
you're mad at your main character
because
you like mal a lot right and he's like
i'm sorry it took me for this long to
see you elena and she's like yeah
like she's owed an apology but she
should be the one apologizing thinking
and judging him that he wouldn't write
to her
and gave up on him come on now and then
what i also thought was
really really bad was when the grisha
gang finds kaz's gang
and there's this woman who passionately
wants to kill
inej because she killed her brother and
that was the one she threw the dagger
out but
how did this woman know it was a niz who
killed her brother
like even when they show the flashback
she wasn't there like this is someone
who hides in the shadow of daggers like
there's no way she would have known this
so that was silly it was and in general
it was silly to even have that
point that they needed that motivation
for her to attack her just so over the
top
and i also don't like and a lot of
netflix shows do this recently where
they show flashbacks
really quick they're not even flashbacks
are little flashes of scenes we just saw
in the prior episode to remind the
audience like
again it's too much hand-holding we know
what the ladies referencing and when i
talked about with bad action right
there's a moment in this battle where
zoya literally
just blows some wind at two people
supposed to be this awesome thing and
it's like
literally like the power of two fans
that are there just blowing dirt up
so silly and where you see more that is
when kaz actually
sees the black general and gets away
from him and he throws this like smoke
bomb to disappear
you'll see that the barrel behind him
from the explosion just like
the top just falls off and it holds up
the camera holds on that and just like
falls to the side it's not like the
barrel explodes or some crazy effect
just yeah so like lame
when you're doing action you know don't
hold back that's where you want to be
over the top you want more there and
then the end of the episode where the
black general
somehow connects that because the
townsperson told him that a tracker was
here that
it was maul and that he must be with
elena
and they must be in the woods and they
must be looking for the stag so he's
just a brilliant
guesser he gets what they're doing to a
t just from that little information so
this episode to me was an absolute
mess i'm going to give it a 5.8 really
did not like it
and it sucks because i really liked
episode before however then
when i was giving up again i really
enjoyed episode seven the unsee
we get the flashback now of alexander
and we get to see
how this all really went down with him
creating a fold it was a really cool
scene when he was
making those soldiers his and when he
created the fold doing that i thought
that was awesome and then we get it
right to some more cool stuff where we
go back to present day and
alina and maul are seeing the stag and
we finally get to see some more
real fantasy stuff here with the show
desperately was missing in the beginning
and you get to see these cool effects
of alina using her powers and doing this
protective shield around her
maul and the stag but it's always cool
to see ben barnes here just slice
this stag's throat i love all the
effects especially with the shadow
summoner worked really well and there's
some really good writing here with kaz
and naja's story he's coming more to his
senses
that elena's for real here doesn't fully
believe she's a saint yet and i have
this really good line where he says no
saint watched over me
like you have which i thought was great
and then we see black generals telling
elena the only thing more powerful than
you and me is
you and me together and that we need to
protect our own talking about the grisha
so he's got those magneto vibes here
and he puts these deer antlers on alina
and i thought it was
really cool to see her with the antlers
coming out of her skin
again adding more fancy to it but also
adding more edge to lina's character
which i thought was much needed and
really cool we also get this reveal that
jenya was a spy
for the black general she wasn't sending
the letters to maul but she
thinks she's doing the right thing so
she's still likeable
but elena's like no we're just pawns for
him what else loves this episode is
there's a scene again
the scenes with maul and the black
general are great something about those
two actors together
and i love this idea that black general
and him
are just fighting over elena and like
him strutting that
he's eternal and he's like i don't care
if she likes you better now like she'll
eventually forgive me i'm not going
anywhere and neither is she you're
mortal and the best line of the show
is when he says i'm not going to kill
you maul i don't need to
time will do it for me that was so
badass i loved it
and ben barnes absolutely crushes it and
it adds more to this
really cool thing about the black
journal's character of him being eternal
because
then elena's connecting all that's like
you caused the fold and then that means
you killed my parents
and that you're who are you and he's
trying to say
everything i've done is to protect
grecia and make rafka safer but she's
calling him out like
everything you actually really do is
just to win it ends with a great
cliffhanger because then we get all our
players together going on the ship
into the fold so i thought it was
actually a great penultimate episode i
give this one an 8.8
and definitely my favorite of the season
but what the show's been doing it's like
up and down the second half of the
season and
as in my hopes go back up then the
finale was
now actually pretty disappointing to me
it's a shorter episode only 44 minutes
titled no mourners and for some reason
to kill all momentum
we have to have about 15 minutes of
scene time with nina and mathias why is
it so
long and it's all just to get that she's
now
betraying grisha is seeing good in this
witch hunter but then it ends up he's in
this cell that she put him in but she
was saved his life he doesn't get that
because he was
passed out and that he's gonna rot in a
cell forever who
freaking cares and the weirdest thing
happens
i'm so nitpicking here but i can't look
past this that
when they're about to have a shootout in
this like bar between the grisha
and the soldiers and nina's scene right
when they're about to like go at it
there's like this awkward moment where
an extra like runs from one side
of the bar to the other was like on the
wrong side and it's just quiet and
it wasn't edited out for some reason it
was really weird it like stops
everything in its tracks
so we see though on the ship mal meets
the cavs crew for the first time
and on top of the ship we get those
intentions clearly stayed now by the
black general that
i'm not destroying the fold like why
would ice is my greatest weapon and then
we see he uses alina's powers with his
to push the fold
destroy this rebel cause in the city and
this will make zoya flip because
her family is in that city and we get
his big speeches big evil plan that he
just wants to redraw maps
engulf places with the fold which is
really cool really hard to pull off a
character like this without being cheesy
over the top and he does it brilliantly
but where i thought there's just a
laughing moment where you roll your eyes
is when mal
finally gets his chance to go kill the
black general on top of the ship
but he first decides to shoot some
randos so it
kills his momentum the only way you're
going to assassinate this guy is if that
was your first shot he did not do that
but at least gets him with the dagger
here which was cool
and i like though the stag appears to
lena here
elena has her big moment coming full
circle now your first words are what
are you this is what i am the stag chose
me so she
connects to take the dagger throw it
through the shadow summoner's hand where
his power's coming from from elena
and jasper has his best moment of the
season when he shoots
the other grecia and he says still
couldn't shoot the pretty face
i gotta stop doing that that was amazing
i know i haven't mentioned him much but
i love jasper through the season he was
great
the actor was great his action sequence
was i think were actually the best
with his gun play and he had a lot of
good humor just very likable so we'll
see the volker actually gets
to the black general and then our team's
now outside the fold anish claims her
loyalty
to lena kazin's so crazy about this kaz
obviously doesn't even want to lose and
niche to lina
as well but elena gives kaz this
necklace to just shut him up
so he's not even thinking about turning
her over for money
she did save their lives as jasper
mentions and setting up season two
they're saying things like
lena who do you think the world will
blame for this zoey is on a journey to
her home city to see what really
happened
cats don't want to lose now she's still
gonna help him for now
but then we see nina now comes to be the
heart render she's going to be for kaz's
crew
appears on the ship ugh like all of that
in a story for that
you know what again would just rather
have her show up on the ship
at the end of the season right there and
then we just like who's this character
we'll find out season two but kaz comes
full circle here mentioning he believes
elena is a saint
and elena and mal have their moment
together when i'm
strong enough will tear down the fold
she says now the darkling is dead i was
worried that they actually killed him
because he's the best character on the
show but thank god he's
actually alive we need more of him i
feel like it's just getting started with
him but this finale felt disjointed
it was just too short and messy but it
was okay i didn't hate it so i'm gonna
give it a 7.7 so adding up all my scores
of each episode i average it out to
about a 7.3 for the season
i'm disappointed as a whole there's a
lot of hype to this because supposedly
the stories are really good the books
and you know netflix was due for a big
fantasy show
but i mean thank god at least the acting
all across the board was great
and in particular i thought any scenes
of ben barnes
and the actress of elena here were
really good like it has
two strong leads and mal is also really
good he's a good character so
having those three strong leads in the
base there
is gonna help the show never just fall
apart and
it still has a good ceiling for season
two if they can kind of fix some messy
writing here
and learn to just cut some things
especially when you're adapting from a
book you can
make sacrifices you don't have to have
everything in it especially if it's
bringing down the show format
and they gotta just get this action
together you can't just have scenes
where little wind is blowing up like
it's gotta be exciting
and everything's gotta count more where
it felt like not everything counted here
and it relied too heavily on the books
that oh the books will make up for this
gotta feel it as a show right and enjoy
it as a show let me know you thought
down below i'd love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment i try to
respond as many as i can
again no book spoilers you can only talk
about what we've seen in the show
nothing ahead please i would leave that
comment don't ruin it for anybody
and just give me your season score any
episodes you want to rate i'd love to
see them all
please follow me at steve arley's show
on twitter instagram for more of me
and please make sure to subscribe my
channel helps me out in so many ways you
have no idea i do a bunch of netflix
shows movies
i do celebrity interviews as well and if
you really like what i do here
i'd really appreciate a two dollar
monthly donation there's a link down
below it's a paypal link
that will help me do videos full time
and i'll be forever grateful thanks so
much for watching and i'll see you next
time